I'm Owen Wilson and I'm a Scout Master with troop number 868 in Peoria, Arizona.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by Backers Like Me.
And now for you, Scout Master.
The Buffalo family was seeing their son off to Scout Camp and Dad Buffalo
patted him on the back and said:
bison by bison, bison. Okay, Wow, That was a reach,
But we're known for that. And the Groners just keep on. coming from Bill McFarland,
who's a Scout Master up there in Pittsfield, Massachusetts,
And I'll put you in touch with him if you'd like to comment.
Hey, this is podcast number 282.. Hey,
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master podcast. This is Clark Green.
We had a lot of encore podcasts this summer so I'm still catching up.
Here's some messages that have been in the mail bag for a while,
but let's get them caught up here.
Mac Barron is with Cub Scout Pack and Boy Scout Troop 75 in Swainsboro, Georgia
And he said:
I can't tell you how much I've enjoyed your blog and podcasts over the past year.
I enjoyed it so much I became a backer and I got a few of your books
which are currently being passed around with my assistant Scout Masters.
My wife and I also have our own podcast we've produced for the last eight years
called Catholic in a Small Town.
Well, thanks, Mac. I certainly appreciate that
And I'll tell you. if you have a chance and an interest, you
check out the podcast that Mac and his wife do.
It's great, Great job.
I'll put a link in the post that contains this podcast.
So in last week's podcast we talked about being a parent and a scouter.
in answer to an email question that I received
And Orin Noah had this comment.
He said:
My proudest moment as a Scout Master was when, after a service project,
the last scout was being picked up by his mom
And I asked my son to get in the truck
and the scout was kind of confused and worried
And he asked my son his patrol leader:
How do you know the Scout Master?
He's my father. my son replied
And the scout said really
He'd been in the troop for at least a year
and never noticed that his patrol leader was the Scout Master's son.
So I figure I did a pretty good job of being Scout Master and not dad.
That's a great reflection on the job that you did, Orin,
And good for you.
Heard from Eric Fletcher, who is with Scout Troop 309
in Orange Ohio,
Said I love the site and I'm finding many useful topics
to train our youth leaders,
And I appreciate your 15-minute patrol leader training.
Well thanks, Eric,
I'm glad you're finding things useful.
We had a couple of quieter chat sessions this week.
We heard from William Schmidt,
who's a Scout Master in Cary, North Carolina,
and Michael McCormick, who is with Troop 48 in Berlin, New Jersey.
So a couple of little bits of business
before we go too much farther.
Summer is drawing to a close,
It's the last day of August
And now is the time to start thinking about summer 2016-
if you haven't started thinking about it already-
And I want to share an opportunity, just an incredible experience,
And I want to invite you to join me next summer
in spending a week at the International Scout Center
in Condorsteg, Switzerland.
The Scout Center has been there for 70 years
And every summer, thousands of Scouts travel to Condorsteg
from all over the world to enjoy adventure in the Alps,
in this wonderful, world-class destination,
and experience the world's fellowship of Scouting
Condorsteg's in the Bernese Oberland,
which is just an amazing, amazing place,
And the number of places to visit
and activities to pursue are almost unlimited.
If you want an idea of what we do
when we go to Condorsteg and how you can join us.
go to scoutmastercgcom.
Right there at the top of the page is a big old picture
And that's Link where you can sign up with your email address
so that I can contact you with details
about how to make all this happen.
You know, for a long time
I kind of watched other people do these types of trips
and do the high-adventure trips and things like that
And I always thought, wow, it's way too expensive.
And I'm really, you know boy,
would I really want to take a group of Scouts overseas.
That sounds really difficult to do.
But listen, the way you end up getting to take your Scouts
for this kind of once-in-a-lifetime experience
is actually pretty simple.
It starts very easily by somebody saying, hey, let's go.
And I want you to be that person and say, hey, you know,
let's go and do this and get the ball rolling
and make it happen.
And if you want to come to Condorsteg with us next summer,
that's fantastic.
But honestly, it really doesn't matter where you go.
You may drive two hours to a national park
and go backpacking for a week.
You may do what we do in some years
and go up to Canada and go canoeing for a week
You may go to the one of the high-adventure bases
or something like that.
It doesn't really matter to me. to tell you the truth,
What really matters is that somebody says, hey, let's go,
Let's actually do this,
Let's make it happen.
So, once again, go to scoutmastercgcom.
Look at the top of the page.
There's a big picture right there of Condorsteg.
Click on that and get some information about this
and come and join me in 2016..
And I need to ask you to do one other thing for me.
If you're a regular reader and listener
and the resources that we've created have helped you,
I'm asking you to return the favor
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
It's pretty simple:
Go to scoutmastercgcom,
Click the support link at the top of the page.
You'll find out how you can financially support this work,
and the funds that we get from backers
go to cover all the expenses of producing and publishing
everything you see at scoutmastercgcom,
including to the podcast that you're listening to right now.
Once again, very easy to do:
Go to scoutmastercgcom,
Click the support link at the top of the page.
And I want to thank Owen Wilson,
who became a backer since our last podcast.
So become a backer this week
and I'll make sure to thank you personally
during our next podcast
This week. we're still in catch-up mode.
I've got some email questions to answer
and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started. shall we
Write me a letter? send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
I heard from Darrell Oakley,
who's an assistant scoutmaster with Troop 132
and Upton, Massachusetts,
And he said: in past podcasts
you've talked about how our weekly meetings
work towards outings
and the general way that this all works together.
I'm interested in when and where
the patrol leaders council meets.
I know that you spoke about them meeting
the first troop meeting night
after an outing weekend.
I'm curious to know what happens to the rest of the troop
that's not part of the patrol leaders council
On those nights. the new BSA troop leader guidebook
suggests that when the patrol leaders council meets,
scouts not in the patrol leaders council
have a chance to catch up on advance advancement work.
So who do you think would be facilitating
that advancement work?
We have several older scouts
who are not on the patrol leaders council
and this seems to be a perfect job for them.
Or is this a time when it's appropriate
to have assistant scoutmasters
more involved with advancement?
Well, Darrell, thanks for that question
and there's some good questions there,
but I'm going to push you around a little bit, okay,
Because I want you to find answers a little differently
than me just laying out a procedure for you.
My habit is to ask what we're doing
and why we're doing it over and over and over again
from a scouts perspective.
I asked that of myself,
I asked that of my fellow adult volunteers
and I asked that of my patrol leaders council.
It's really simple to get ourselves distracted
by policy and procedure and their own motives, right?
What we often do is we often forget
to kind of keep it simple
and we get distracted by policy and procedure
and the motives that they intend.
But all we really need to do is
is to look at this from a scouts perspective
and help them get stuff done.
Now, if you think of these things
in terms of that basic perspective,
what we do begins to make sense.
So you mentioned, as I've repeated in the past,
the reason that we're having weekly meetings
is to get camping right,
And the reason that we go camping
is because that's something that scouts do,
and when scouts go camping,
they do all kinds of stuff,
including things that satisfy
advancement requirements.
So we're never really saying,
oh, it's advancement time,
We're always advancing,
We're always working on something,
because we're always doing what scouts do.
and that's maybe a little bit of a different approach
than saying, oh, we're going to put this time aside
to do just advancement type stuff
and to catch everybody up.
So from that perspective,
how would you answer your own question?
And Daryl got back to me and said:
well, if I were to answer my own question
I would probably repeat exactly
what the senior patrol leader told me
said: you know, while we're having
our patrol leaders council meeting,
let's have some of the older scouts
who aren't in the patrol leaders council
help the younger scouts,
And that makes sense to me.
but I was really generally interested
in hearing what your troop did
when the patrol leaders council met.
making these kinds of changes
causes heartburn, mostly for the adults.
Adults do get heartburn,
but it's not necessarily about the changes.
It's about kind of the frustration
built into the process
and I'll explain what that means
Why. your question is pretty simple
And I will. I will in a moment
just tell you exactly what we do procedurally.
My answer really is not about how things happen
or the procedure that we follow
as why they happen the way that they do.
So first of all let me explain
how we did things. the procedure
And again I'll mention the process
behind deciding on how we do things
is more important, but more about that later.
So procedurally right,
our patrol leaders council
meets before and after
each weekly meeting for a few minutes
and once a month
for a longer session
in the place of a troop meeting.
So we don't have a troop meeting
on that troop meeting night,
We have a patrol leaders council meeting.
So when the patrol leaders council meets
it's just them and nobody else.
So the scout master
and that is only the scout master.
so no committee members,
no assistant scout masters.
He's the only adult
who attends the patrol leaders council meeting
and listens quietly most of the time,
only speaking when spoken to
with a couple of minutes
for their thoughts and reflections. at the end
Darren wrote back and he said:
well, I like the patrol leaders council meeting.
during the first troop meeting night
after a camp out
I talked with this about it
with our senior patrol there and scout master,
but you still haven't told me
what scouts who aren't involved
with the patrol leaders council do that evening.
I think some troops have boards of review that night,
so it doesn't interfere
with regular troop meetings the rest of the month.
Well, Darren, yes,
When the patrol leader council meets,
okay, it's not a troop meeting at all,
It's a patrol leaders council meeting.
It's held the same night as a troop meeting
after the weekend camp out.
We do have boards of review
and scout master conferences.
I mean, they're available if scouts need them.
Our troop quarter master
will take the time to work
with his patrol quarter masters
to check in all the gear
that was used during the camping trip
on that evening.
And scouts who aren't otherwise involved
with any of those activities
don't show up on that night.
They just don't come to that meeting.
Now I think the idea
that older scouts could catch up
on advancement where the younger scouts
has some merit, okay,
It's not a bad idea objectively.
but it begs a number of questions
that the scout master
can ask the patrol leaders council,
And this furthers what I'm trying to communicate,
which is process rather than procedurally oriented.
So what would the scout master ask
if the patrol leaders council suggested,
hey, let's have all the scouts come
and work on advancement
with the older scouts?
Well, what I would ask is:
if the older scouts are there
to help younger scouts,
what are they working on specifically
And who plans and decides
what they'll be doing?
And not only who plans and decides that,
but how will they be planning
and carrying out that aspect
of that particular night?
Do the older scouts have a current
position of responsibility at all?
Do they need one to advance?
Are they going to be asked
or assigned to carry out this idea?
Has anybody asked them
if they even want to do it?
And what happens if we just have
a general invitation,
all the scouts show up
and a few of them have no advancement
to catch up on?
And why are we doing advancement
in a separate thing like this
instead of as part of our regular program?
Does that mean that we need to
be paying more attention
to advancement in the regular program,
Or are we already adequately addressing that?
So that's a lot of questions
And I can tell you what we do in our troop.
but the point isn't really
how we do things,
but why we ended up doing them right
And the engagement of the youth leadership
in making those things happen.
So that list of questions
that I would ask,
if the senior patrol leader
suggested this as an idea.
we'll have some answers
and those answers will provide me
with the opportunity to ask more questions,
And it's really kind of an endless cycle
of questions and answers,
and then more questions
and more answers
until they go through that process
and they begin to develop an idea
of how they're going to accomplish
whatever it is that we're talking about.
So we aren't looking for the answer right
In a set of procedures or policies
or practices that we can adopt
that somebody else did.
What we're looking for
is engaging our scouts
in a process of finding their answers,
And if that answer turned out
to look exactly like what I do,
well, you know,
maybe that means that I'm very smart
or just that you know,
we had a case
where people arrived
at the same conclusions.
The process involved
in arriving at our decisions
with the patrol leaders council
is really more important
than the decisions themselves,
because procedures
and practices and policies-
they change all the time
and they really aren't all that important.
The process of how you develop
a practice or a procedure
is where all of the growth
and development happens for our scouts
and the aim of our work.
So Darren asked me
a pretty simple question:
How do you run these meetings.
Okay, my answer was:
well, it's not really important
about how I run these meetings.
What's important is
the basic logic behind
what we're up to right,
Which is
scouts join scouting
to do the things that scouts do,
which is to go camping
with their buddies.
and when they go camping
with their buddies,
they got to do all this stuff.
They have to build fires
and set up tents
and decide on campsites,
and what does that sound like?
Well, those are advancement requirements, right?
So we're doing those
in the natural course
of the activities that we're pursuing,
and so it kind of begs the question for me:
why do you have to have
a separate time for advancement?
This should be happening right
As we're doing things,
and I can understand
having some time set aside-
especially if it's a larger troop-
for older scouts to sit down
and to sign requirements off
for younger scouts
or something like that.
But again, you know,
my question would be:
well, why isn't this happening
just in the natural course
of what we're doing?
But I repeat myself again,
the most important thing
is engaging our youth leadership
in this process
of looking at the basic logic of scouting,
answering a lot of questions
and to beginning to develop
their own resolutions
and answers and procedures
and practices,
because that's really
the work that we're aimed at.
That's really what develops
character and leadership
and responsibility in our scouts.
So I hope that's not too confusing.
Scouting is not easy to get sometimes,
because it's all about
what we're really aimed at
and not necessarily
the practices and procedures
we use to get there.
Once you understand the aim,
once you understand
what's really important,
then all the other pieces
fall into place pretty naturally.
I heard from Ty Williams
in Clarkston, Washington. Clarkston-
What a lovely name for a town,
Wouldn't you say? huh.
Anyway, Ty wrote in
to ask me this question.
He says I'm going to be scout master
for a young troop
and really we're working
with the charter organization
to get the troop up
and running again.
It's been dormant for a while.
We'll have six youth
when the charter is signed.
Five of them
will be Weebelow's crossovers.
So how do we adult volunteers
guide these youth
in the patrol method
when they're so young?
I do have one scout
that is 17
who's volunteered to participate
with the troop
as a senior scout
and help out.
Well, Ty, it sounds
like you have a great thing going
and it may seem small
and the scouts may seem young.
but these are not barriers,
These are your strengths.
Okay,
And you're going to give them
a wonderful experience
because with that many guys,
you have a patrol,
So there's no need
for a senior patrol leader
or patrol leaders council
or anything like that.
Don't get distracted
by those things.
If I was in your shoes,
what I would do
is I would sit down
with that older scout
and tell him
he's going to be
the patrol leader
for the next three months
and that he has these three goals.
The first is
to plan and execute
three monthly activities,
with at least two of them
being camping overnight.
you know, accepting
that you're getting up
and getting moving
and getting rolling,
I think getting two campouts
in in the next three or four
months is a pretty good goal.
So to prepare
for those activities,
he'll need to do some planning
right
And he'll need to plan
the patrol meetings
that you're going to have
every week
to train
and prepare his scouts
to go camping
and to do whatever they've planned.
So the second goal
is, in three months' time
he'll have trained all of his scouts
to take over
his job as patrol leader
and they'll have an election
and they'll choose
the next patrol leader.
And the third goal
is that
he'll get all his scouts
to advance
at least one rank
in those three months.
Now, from there,
you can open up a conversation
that's going to go on
while he's the patrol leader, right,
He can start telling you
what he'll need from you.
You'll make it a point
to discuss
how things are going often
and you'll be there
if he has any questions.
But you'll begin asking questions.
So how are you going to make
these goals work?
What are your three monthly activities?
What do your meeting plans look like?
Do you need help
putting those together?
How are your scouts doing on advancement?
What do you need to do with them?
Is that part of your activity plan?
Is that part of your meeting plan?
How are you going to get all these guys
to scout rank
or to tender foot
within this next three months?
So it sounds like a big challenge
and it is,
but keep an open dialogue
and you're going to be amazed
at how things go.
If you have an older scout
who's really interested in doing this-
and having that amount of
responsibility
seems to motivate him-
you're good to go
and I'll be really interested
to hear how things happen.
Here's an anonymous question:
Is there an official BSA policy
on asking registered adults
to leave the troop.
Hmm, we have a pair of parents
who continue to attend
troop meetings
and committee meetings
after their sons have moved on,
They've graduated from high school
and they've gone on to college,
and neither of these people
have any position in the troop
and they intend to be disruptive
and divisive and difficult.
How do we get them out of our hair?
Well, there's no official policy
or procedure I've ever found
that outlines exactly how to do this.
It's a pretty simple thing to do, though.
Now I will say this:
it's a pretty rare thing
that we need to ask somebody
to step away
from a volunteer position,
but these folks don't have a position.
I guess they're just staying
registered with the troop
for one reason or another.
but if they're being disruptive
and difficult,
you can try and play nice
and you can try and talk to them
and you can try to resolve things,
but sometimes that just doesn't work.
so what do you do next?
Well, the chartered organization
representative and the committee
chairman put their heads together
and they send a letter-
and this is a real paper snail mail
letter in an envelope, right,
And they can hand deliver a copy.
they can put it in the mail
however they want to handle it.
but it's a real letter,
not an email,
and I'll talk about that in a second.
So the letter states very clearly
that these folks are not allowed
to attend meetings, committee meetings
or any function of the unit,
and in this letter
you don't have to state causes.
this is not like firing an employee
or you're telling a volunteer
that their involvement
is no longer necessary.
So let me give you an idea
of what I would put in a letter like that.
it would be: you know,
Dear Mr and Mrs X,
as representative of the chartering organization
of our troop,
this letter serves as notification
that you are not to attend
any function or meetings of the troop
in any capacity.
I'm taking this action
on behalf of our chartering organization
after receiving complaints
about undue interference
with the troops volunteers.
this decision is final.
there will be no further discussion.
Now that all sounds really harsh and mean,
but if you've worked to try
and resolve this
and they're not working along with you,
they're not really going to take a hint.
you have to spell this out
pretty carefully
and it's almost certain
you aren't going to win them over with kindness.
I want to reiterate:
don't email this notice,
because email
takes on a life of its own.
the best course
is to either mail
the letter
or hand deliver it,
and hand delivery,
I think, would probably be the option
that I would take
now. there'll likely be a reaction,
and it may be a very ugly reaction,
but there is no recourse
through the council
or the district
because charter organizations
have the absolute authority
to choose who volunteers
and to fire volunteers at any time,
for cause or no cause at all.
Now your scout executive
and your district executive
would probably appreciate a copy of the letter,
but you don't really need their approval or permission
as long as you have
the permission and approval
of the charter organization
to take this course of action.
nobody likes situations like this.
they come up from time to time.
thankfully, they're not very common,
and because they're so uncommon,
we sometimes aren't quite sure what to do,
and I offer my advice.
I have never been able to find
a specific policy statement
or procedure
about how to get rid of a volunteer,
and my advice is premised
on the assumption that
you've already talked this around
and you tried to resolve this with them
and it just ain't gonna work
okay.
so if you know of policies or procedures
that do affect this
and would shed some light on the question.
please do get in touch with me.
while we're talking about difficult stuff,
here's an email that came to me
from a youth member
and I'll mention very quickly.
I'm happy to receive communication
from youth members.
I always tell them
to please include a parent
in any future emails.
I follow the BSA policy
of always making sure there's somebody else-
and preferably that's the child's parent-
is a party to the conversation
I'm gonna have via email
with a youth member.
but anyway, let's get back to this question.
we have a scout in our troop
who has probably some mental health issues
and he's usually a very good scout,
but sometimes he'll kind of go off
on either me or my father,
the scout master.
we have a true policy that I've written
and submitted to the patrol leaders council,
as I am a patrol leader.
this policy has discussed behavioral issues
such as scouts breaking the scout oath and law.
I sure do not hope that we will have to ask this scout to leave,
but I also don't want him to physically harm anybody.
you really don't need a policy
or a set of rules
because you already have them
and this is the scout oath and law.
you do not want
or need anything else,
and I'll explain why. in my answer,
I also want to make sure that it's understood
that I do not think
it is a good idea for youth leaders
to try and manage difficult behavior on their own.
this is why adults volunteer for scouting
to help you handle these types of things.
this is one for the adults.
okay,
so let's just talk about misbehavior in general.
scout misbehaves
causes a problem.
the next step is:
is he's going to sit down and talk to the scout master?
the scout master is going to discuss this with him
and hopefully arrive at a resolution,
and that's what will happen
nine out of ten times.
maybe somebody got angry,
maybe somebody got out of line
or went off, like you said,
and they need to make some apologies,
patch things up,
and it's very easy to do that way.
I want to add right here
for the adult scouters who are listening in:
let's remember,
as scouters
we don't ever use corrective punishment.
sometimes there's proportionate consequences to an action.
if they made a mess
or they broke something,
they have to clean up the mess
or fix something.
maybe they have to apologize to somebody.
but we never use punishment
and we especially never allow our youth leaders
to use any kind of punishment whatsoever.
we do not punish.
that is a parent's job.
back to what I was saying:
if there is an instance of misbehavior,
the scout's going to sit down
and talk to the scout master.
and exactly what happens
when the scout master talks to the scout
is not something I can absolutely define for you,
because every instance of bad behavior
needs to be addressed on its own.
every person
and every interaction they have with other people
it's going to be different in one way or another,
and that's why you don't want
specific policies, procedures and rules
to be written about things like this,
because you have to deal with these
on an individual basis.
so there's some very simple, logical things
that happen when the scout master
and the scout are talking to each other.
if they can, as I said, resolve the problem
then and there-
and this happens most of the times
because you know scouts are usually pretty good
and misbehavior isn't usually all that bad-
then we're done.
if it's a pattern of misbehavior-
if the same thing happens more than once,
that's a pattern-
then it's usually time to involve the scout's parents-
and I say usually
because it all depends on those individual elements
that I was speaking about-
and when the scout's parents get involved.
the message to them is simple:
your son is misbehaving
and he can't participate in scouts until you can assure us
corrected that misbehavior
and he will be able to
observe the scout oath and law while he's here with us.
so take him home,
work this out
and when you're sure he can behave
according to the scout oath and law,
bring him back.
it's pretty simple that way.
so that's why you only want the oath and law
as your guide to conduct and behavior,
and the only other thing you need
then that is a scout master
who is kind and interested in helping his scouts.
if you make a set of rules and policies,
you end up being a police officer and a judge.
if you rely on the oath and law
as the standard for behavior,
you're able to be a counselor
and to work with scouts individually
and resolve whatever difficulties they're having.
now, from what you're telling me about this particular scout,
I would suggest that the scout master
sit down with his parents,
tell them they have some work to do
and that the scout really can't participate
until they can assure the scout master
he will not misbehave.
if he's been physically threatening,
that would be the next thing I would do
about this situation
and the message I would send to the scout
at the same time is: look,
you know
you've got a problem that you need to resolve.
I can't resolve it for you.
I'm here to help you
and to talk about it as much as possible,
but this is a job for you and your parents to do
and we really hope that you resolve it quickly
so you can come back and be with us again.
if you have a comment about what you've heard
on the podcast today,
or you'd like to get in touch with me
with your own question,
you can do that. it's pretty easy
and I'm going to tell you
how to make that happen in just a moment.
Thank you for listening to this 280 second edition of the scout master podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
join the nearly 10,000 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
tweet along with the chorus
of 1,200 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the pultritudinous pictures
we proffer publicly
with 1,900 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
you can watch our videos
at scoutmastercg on YouTube
if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you bitter,
if you have no interest in Pinterest
and if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
that's alright. Bunky,
just zoom into the late 1990s
and send me an email.
you can email me, Clark Green,
your questions and comments
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
alternatively, the next time
you're seated around a campfire,
if you and your scouts repeat
scoutmastercg three times
while looking in a mirror,
I will magically appear
and answer your questions.
what you're hearing on the podcast
and everything at scoutmastercgcom
are not official publications
of anybody in particular
other than myself.
we're not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization
for that matter.
nope, no, no, no,
not at all.
it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping.
oh, I thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.